c'est un symbole de la france à
l'étranger
le vin de bourgogne s'exporte très bien
et notamment aux états unis premier
importateur depuis 2014 à quelques
semaines des fêtes de fin d'année chez
ce viticulteur
les cartons sont prêts à traverser
l'atlantique
ces deux palettes qui vont partir
direction new york
avec différentes appellations aussi bien
des blancs que
que des rouges c'était sans compter sur
le compte twitter de donald trump sur
son réseau social favori le président
américain menace d'augmenter les taxes
sur le vin français qui entrent aux
états unis pour cette entreprise
familiale qui exportent 10% de sa
production
ce pourrait être un coup dur 5 10 15 20
30 % d'augmentation de taxes parce que
dans ces genres de choses on ne sait pas
jusqu'où il peut ça peut aller aura
forcément une répercussion vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis de nos importateurs parce que
ben si vous mettiez interne un tiers de
plus dans le prix d'une bouteille due à
des taxes le client final mais il va
regarder à deux fois pour pour acheter
pour acheter une bouteille mais les
taxes dont parle donald trump sont elles
vraiment plus élevés en france qu'aux
états unis selon les professionnels des
vins de bourgogne sur le vin blanc ali
de quelques centimes d'écart par
bouteille alors qu'elle est quasi
inexistante en ce qui concerne les vins
rouges pour les négociants bourguignons
la réaction de donald trump est infondée
faut savoir que ces taxes ont été fixés
il ya déjà plus de vingt ans que les
états unis ont les mêmes droits les
mêmes avantages que les autres pays mais
nouveau monde dans l'union européenne et
que on va dire qu'il y à une stabilité
des relations
reste que les saillies du président
américain sont à prendre très au sérieux
les vins et les spiritueux sont le
deuxième marché d'exportation français à
l'étranger